lagarde tout historique à double titre
d'abord parce qu'elle a accueilli sous
un même toit deux compagnies
ferroviaires l'une publique l'autre
privée
ensuite parce qu'elle a réuni les trois
disciplines des beaux-arts architecture
sculpture et peinture il ya neuf
tableaux en céramique peinte l ouest y
en a neuf aussi c'est ses tableaux
représentent des différentes saynètes
on peut dire ça qui donne envie aux gens
de voyager
installé en 1896 les céramiques
nécessité d'une restauration urgente
mais coûteuse elle a été possible grâce
à l'aide de l'association patrimoine
environnement est là sur sa plateforme
ulule lancé une opération de ce qu'on
appelle le crowfunding qui en fait du
financement participatif 200 personnes
200 généreux donateurs ont répondu à
l'appel et maintenant c'était via trois
en deux ans et demi trois ans et
maintenant nous mettons en oeuvre la
restauration annie volta assure cette
restauration d'autant plus délicate que
les céramiques ont subi la tacc des
poussières de charbon rejetée par les
locomotives à vapeur
on a eu des cas sur avec des éclats et
certains carreaux étaient manquants et
avait été reconstituée soit avec du bois
soit avec du plâtre appliquées de
manière très grossière et peint on voit
là ici par exemple après nettoyage que
le ciel redevient tout à fait de
couleurs éclatantes
alors qu'on voit bien ici où la couleur
de l'encrassement très foncée et qui
masque beaucoup de détails sur les fonds
des carreaux notamment les petites
nuances de couleurs des du ciel et puis
certains détails qu'on aperçoit en fait
ou qu'on ne re découvre qu après
nettoyage en janvier
les sommes seront réinstallés et les
voyageurs tourangeau pourront de nouveau
reprendre leurs rêves de voyage dans la
gare de victor laloux